what's going on there reject nation if
you didn't catch our reaction to the
official trailer trailer 2 for doctor
strange and multiverse and madness it's
linked in a variety of places in this
video got our expert coy with us and now
there's a doctor strange tv spot that
apparently has a bunch of new footage in
there as well that's not in the official
trailer they're feeding us man they're
feeding us
right now we got a dessert let's get to
it leave a like if you can
what do you know about the multiverse
[Music]
oh damn
we should tell them
just
they're just our defenders straight
still insane
holy [ __ ] he's a zombie
tall
we just got three different strangers in
that trailer yeah there were three one
of which is the what if strange that's
what are the what if they're just
there's yeah one of them there's many
one and strangers at that point
we have the defender strange zombie
strange zombie strange and then of
course in the actual trailers we're
beginning
yes we got four strangers it looked like
there were two wanders unless they just
cut it that way that's gonna be the
issue i think with all these trailers
what's real and what are they
manipulating for us i wonder if there's
gonna be some kind of weird zombie
interlude because wanda looked way more
jacked up in that shot than she did in
the actual trailer where she's standing
there with them and what is canon so why
not use the thing that's going to be so
cinematically prevalent that kevin would
just show a strange supreme tell them
about strange supreme okay so strange
supreme is basically the the ultimate id
run rampant he is the the most
egotistical version of doctor strange
who does anything at any cost for the
sake of saving rachel mcadams i'm
slipping on her real name jane no that's
her lady christine wow i know i don't
read christine palmer jesus thank you i
appreciate that that's why i don't show
down that's why they show down we're big
christine palmer fans
that being said he'll do anything for
her we also have a defender strange in
this which is going to be someone that's
kind of the other extreme this is
someone who's actively selfless this is
someone who's going to sacrifice
everything so that dichotomy is going to
be dope and currently in the comic books
right now there's this really cool
storyline called death of doctor strange
where the comic universe is doctor
strange is killed and they have a
basically a save point doctors change
from the 60s who comes back using magic
and solves the mystery of strange's own
death so a 1960s doctor strange who
still says the fun like stan lee's steve
ditko area like haromf is investigating
modern strange and i do feel like it's
not a coincidence that comic book is
basically setting up for this
multiversal impact so i feel like we
might even get some time play some
different versions interacting to solve
problems where his arrogance might be
his folly i think defender strange is
going to be the one that is able to
solve the issue of the arrogance of
strange at the cost of the multiverse
okay interesting i wonder how many
strangers are going to die in this movie
i think it's going to be a bloodbath
yeah it's kind of amazing
i think we're going to kill a lot of
scarlets you think so yeah cause that
shot of scarlet versus i think we got a
shot of wanda versus scarlet in that
trailer that looked like wanda fighting
a scarlet the way they edited that
together i'm wondering if they're gonna
make the villainous wanda be a the one
who was featured more prominently in the
trailer the one in the actual scarlet
witch outfit right do you think one
division's scarlet is going to be evil
or do you think she turns out to be good
we got to learn how to talk about which
wanda we're talking about welcome to
comics it's in the comic books you've
got the 616 universe you've got the 1610
universe you've universities they don't
establish what you know like the
universe titles as well
in the movies i was talking to john ray
before it looks like we have the
illuminati in the bigger trailer and i'm
wondering if if the rumors are true i
know nothing more than you because i
don't want to i'm wondering if what a
great way to introduce a multiversal
illuminati iron man's usually on the
illuminati what if tom cruise is just
chilling at a table it's like hey yeah
that seems to be the big theory and then
he just runs pointlessly that's it
i gotta save the multiplayers so i think
if we have multiple versions of everyone
that would allow for certain characters
to be other cast members we had patrick
stewart's voice again which was just as
chill inducing inducing i do feel like
we could have multiple scarlet witch's
multiple doctor strangers and then
variants of our other leads what was
going on with christine palmer though
because in the actual trailer when
they're doing that like like what i call
the doctor who shot
and they're opening the door you see
america chavez behind him and then you
see chris a different version of
christine palmer behind him but there
was a different shot here like you see a
more a clear shot of her in the red hair
and she's like working in the lab i
think those are two different christian
followers yeah that's what i'm getting
at what do you think
you could have started the question just
let me finish my question i was able to
follow this yeah
looks like wanda is breaking into where
that christine palmer is
i assume it's gonna be multiple attempts
to save christine paul is there a
scientist version of her i mean in canon
she's always night nurse to my knowledge
who is saving people so a variation of
that could be someone who's a scientist
who's doing lab work who's doing science
to save someone so it's not too far of a
stretch she's a very benevolent always
savior character of heroes so it
wouldn't be too far to go like doctor
that's fair you know i mean like it
tracks
these trailers have both been such kind
of overwhelming cacophonies of
name check madness but uh but yeah just
the amount of possibility like i i love
that in this post post post spiderman no
way home age of like oh man like
speculation and rumors everything is so
rampant i feel like these trailers are
well engineered to like give you a
shotgun blast of things that you can
easily run off with that i have no idea
how will end up or pay off and so as
weary as i guess with the
feature length film iteration of these
now especially when there is a huge
story to cover and a lot of action to do
this still looks somehow like it could
be just as satisfying of a crazy story
and also a mad cap adventure with tons
and tons of new locations and variant
you know iterations of people so uh yeah
i mean this looks absolutely epic and
somehow it still looks like a doctor
strange movie yeah an avengers movie
that's called doctor strange and i'm
happy for that
i think it was really key to get sam
raimi for that purpose to make sure the
look and tone felt so different because
i to this day think captain america
civil war feels like a cap film i know a
lot of people call it avengers 2.5 but
this to me even more than civil war
looks to be in that universe specific of
the doctor strange niche and i do feel
like that's going to benefit going
forward because kevin feige was very
clear that the infiniti saga was huge
but this was a lot bigger and though
they've had to deal with a lot of covid
delays and adjustments and changes and
you know there's a lot of things that
had to change even in no way home but
the satisfaction we got from no way home
the bar's high but this looks like it
could do it well i think doctor strange
of himself there's very few characters
who come with a genre and he
literally there's a genre you bring with
dr strange and it seems to be so heavily
on that genre supernatural magical [ __ ]
is the name of that genre so stan lee
and steve ditko guys knew what they were
doing i have no idea who you're talking
yeah they're great guys they're i'll
introduce you you mean amy pascal i mean
i mean amanda paul
finger of bob kane
what's wrong with you guys jerry siegel
fantastic brian michael bendis clearly
not my term doctor strange all right
guys
thanks for being here you know what why
would cap this off with a page
fleb doran flev uh it is like protocol
that we shout you out on a marvel video
once a month so now that we have arrived
at another marvel video i just want to
say thank you so much for being you do
you know what the name flev means koi i
don't know but i like it well koi i want
you to venture to guess what the name
flev means use it in a sentence a verb
if you will uh flev as a verb well i was
running late but then after consuming a
monster energy drink i flipped right
along
that's not a bag
i got a little enthusiasm
means like an extra dose of some type of
adrenaline push to allow yourself to uh
that was a great guess i mean i'm making
money right now i have no idea oh it
means well here we are trying to
interpret what you're doing yeah right
it's a little extra it's like the the
mario red mushroom
this is what happens when we run out of
things to say during shout outs thanks
[Music]